hello and welcome again to Android
design in action my name is Roman Eric
hey guys Adam Kosh hi Nick Gocha and
today we have way too much content so
we're just going to get started today's
episode is on device automation apps the
app that will be looking at today is
called tasker and then we'll also go
into a deep dive on touch feedback and
then we have a good amount of design use
to cover as well so let's just get
started so if we can look at the slide
chef I can't really see if we're looking
there but I guess we are okay so this is
on the left side the tasker app now I'm
Tasker is basically a device automation
app in the App clinic they kind of use
the term profile device profile apps
this is kind of I guess a subset of that
basically it lets you create a system of
constraints or contexts and create a set
of actions or tasks I guess tasks are
collections of actions in this amp that
that get run when the device enters that
kind of profile that context so for
example if if the date or if the week
day is monday through friday and the
time of days between 9pm and 5 p.m. and
5pm you can be thought as like in the
work profile or in the work a set of
context and then so once you enter that
context rather enter that profile
there's a lot of terminology in the
Sabbats it's somewhat confusing but it's
you know it's very well thought out when
you enter the contact certain things can
happen when you leave that context of
profile other things can happen so
there's an enter and exit action so
that's a you know at a very high level
what the app does it lets you how to do
a number of different things from you
know from setting system settings
automatically to you know speaking out
text to doing all sorts of interesting
things and of course the number of
different profiles or or different
constraints that they have is also very
large so you can really really customize
that the set of behaviors you want so
this is the app as you can see here
there's kind of these three tabs
profiles
and scenes we're not only going to talk
about scenes that much because I anisty
didn't really get a feel for what they
were the profiles and tasks are two of
the most important things here so here
we have a single profile which is my
work profile and on the left you see the
the different contexts that need to be
satisfied to be in this profile and then
in the right hand you the right hand
side you see the basically the actions
that occur when you enter or exit in
this case there's only an interaction so
when you exit this profile like you know
when you leave work basically nothing
will happen there won't be like an
unmetered anything and then set to
unleash upon dead as soon as you get to
work yeah I couldn't really find the
better icon for muting unfortunately the
the built-in icons didn't really have a
really obvious mute icon so I just shows
a panther because they're cute and
cuddly okay and basically here you know
there's some standard stuff there's
these actions in the bottom that let you
add things you know add a profile in
this case except and cancel changes turn
Tasker on and off as a whole and then to
edit things on the screen there's a lot
of long pressing going on which you know
as if you look through our guidelines on
gestures you should really reserved long
press for other things but there's a lot
of complex interactions and a lot of
stuff going on on the screen so that's
why we chose to think of a kind of a
reimagining what it could look like
Before we jump into the redesign Nick
Adam any thoughts I'm this ask you to my
radar for quite some time I think they
won't want the early Android developer
challenge is and I think you know the
features you described a super powerful
right but I've always been put off or
whenever I get to the Play Store listing
right and you see their screenshots it's
very intimidating looking like a all the
different I have no idea what a lot of
different kind of controls refer to and
the plethora of options it seems to
offer up so it's pretty excited it got
look at this application try and make it
you know make all that power that's a
little easier to tap into yeah
absolutely yeah let's just move on okay
so let's look at the redesign so this is
the the reimagining of the tasker home
screen so on the right-hand side I'm
going to zoom in here so you can see on
the right hand side here we have you
know tasker and obviously we've refitted
it with while we're saying refitted
sounds like exhibits what's that kind of
car refitting show that he had am i
right am i right it sounds like pimping
riots or anything whatever so so weary
fitted it with a plasma screen TVs gonna
fold yeah we've done a plasma screen
okay we should really fly through this
is way too much content so we have you
know we fitted it with the standard
action bar and tab bar we basically
taken their core tab bar that they've
had in the previous screen here and
we've made it look more Hollow obviously
we feel that you know these tabs are
probably fine you know separating it out
to bringing out the app into these three
core sections is probably okay it's
really up to the app to decide what
their information architecture is but we
left it as is but and we've put the
we've moved the the on off switch for
the entire app to the top right as a key
action in this case you know some could
argue that you shouldn't have actions in
both the top right and in the split
action bar but in this case it's really
kind of like a global it's not really an
action it's really look at AAG look a
high level toggle for the entire app so
we felt that it was appropriate there
and then in the content of the screen
you see your profiles but here you can't
really edit the profiles and this is one
of the things that I found that was a
little confusing with the preview or
with the current app is that viewing the
list of profiles and editing in an
individual profile is all in one screen
it almost being it almost be like you
know seeing a list of contacts and
editing each contact all in once almost
like a spreadsheet and it just felt
overbearing so we decided to split this
screen up into two screens we're on one
screen you see the list of profiles and
you can obviously turn them on and off
which is a simple you know action that
you can take
but then to to edit the profile you know
you touch once to get into the details
and we'll show you then so here you see
the list of contexts you know this is
called my mute at work profile and
there's the list of context or
constraints they need to be fulfilled
and then when you enter it mutes and
when you leave it unmute and then here's
an example of a profile that's turned
off for example send I'm coming home as
a text message and we've decided to turn
that off and there's no exit action
there's only a single interaction there
and then you can add a profile using the
standard action bar action there and
there's another feature inside of the
menu you know deep in there somewhere
which is search Tasker which I don't
exactly know what it did but it was just
kind of like a global search through the
app we decided to expose that as an
action in the bottom left before move on
any comments should we fly through
keeping okay let's keep God so in in
this in the same exact screen that you
saw in the beginning right you see this
this kind of both viewing a list of
profiles and editing a profile screen
this is the editing portion that we
broke up into a separate screen we're
here you see the you know the profile
itself the enter and exit actions that
you can select using a spinner and then
you can there's a little shortcut here
to edit each of these tasks and again a
task is a collection of actions which
we'll see in a bit and then to add a
context or add a constraint you simply
would you know press this inline Add
button and of course you could put this
in the action bar if you want but it is
just a sort minh of different types of
ways you can expose this and then to
remove something you just swipe to
dismiss it and then there are probably
other actions you can take on each
individual context for example you know
editing should just be a OneTouch thing
but if you want to duplicate it or clone
it or something maybe that could be
exposed through and like an overflow
affordance and obviously if you want to
delete multiple things you should you
should allow for multiple selection
using contextual action bar
okay the next screen and this is this is
an example of selecting a task so when
you exit when you exit this mute at work
profile here the list of things you
could do you can say oh there's no exit
task where you can browse all tasks and
manage tasks or you can select one of
the existing lindsay has are pretty
straightforward nothing nothing fancy
there on the next screen this is
basically where you're editing a task
and you can see here this you know
there's a lot of you know there are a
lot of objects that you deal with in
this app and so one of the core points
overall with this redesign is to
simplify things to make it very obvious
of what you're working with and so you
know here you're working with you know a
list of actions for a task and
previously you're working with a list of
you know contexts for a profile so you
want to make it very very clear
throughout every step in the process
what the types of data you're working
with is and where in the structure it is
so here is another example of how you
can kind of use swipe to dismiss and a
simple add action here at the top to
replace a bunch of you know buttons that
are on screen for like deleting and and
adding and things like that and actually
here you'll notice that there's no real
way to delete something you have to long
press to delete which is it seems kind
of like extra work to have to do that I
think there's there's probably one or
two more this is the the place where you
can kind of rename a task so if you jump
into the task details you should be able
to edit everything one of the ways you
could do that is to have like an inline
text field with the name so you just
start you know changing the name right
there and then or if if you don't think
that that's going to be a very common
thing you could move it into the action
overflow is kind of like a rename
additional actually and I think the last
screen should i want to show here is
adding an action this is one of the more
important parts so actually this is
adding yet this is adding an action not
a context so when you add an action like
you know when it is time to or when I
work for example mute the phone or you
know speak some text or whatever you
know airplane mode whatever to do that
in the current app you have to kind of
go into a browse mode where you see this
overwhelmingly large set of things you
can do and it's kind of hard to really
find the finger looking for and I think
in this case you're generally more in
search mode rather than browse mode so i
think that you know it'd be be a better
case here to basically have an
autocomplete so if i'm in the list of
actions to take i just start typing
volume or mute or something and it gives
me a pre-populated auto completed list
of things that i can do and as soon as I
touch it just adds it and if there's
configuration steps and it just shows a
configuration set so I think that was it
I know those super funds we will do that
in 12 minutes knife anything else you
guys want to say before we move on from
from the screen redesigns I really like
the way it feels a lot cleaner now I
think generally dialogues just aren't
the answer the previous actually popped
up a lot of dialogues which kept a lot
of context and a lot of load on the
easiest kind of remember where they are
I feel like the new setup with the
before and after it just feels a lot
easier to use I mean yeah and this up in
general is just really complicated like
it does a lot of things and so I think
breaking them into a back-breaking the
different functions at different screens
really really helps helps the user
navigate through these different
sections yeah really in this case it's
simplifying actually there's there's a
lot of cases in the past where we've
combined multiple screens into one I
think that this app can can do well by
splitting things up more since it's so
complex Before we jump to the touch
feedback session I just want to briefly
talk about some iconography well
actually I guess branding and actually
it's really just branding this umbrella
of branding this is the current icon on
the left and here's kind of what it
could look like matching the redesign
theme so the redesign theme is kind of
like a blue and orange color scheme and
so here's what it could look like with
that color scheme and this better fits
some of the other app icons that are out
there just purely in terms of styling
not so much in iconography which is kind
of the most important thing to to be
memorable
you're taking out what is in the icon
but to make it feel a little more modern
and you know up to par with with some of
the other apps that are out there and
then the last thing I want to mention is
the lack of a feature graphic you cannot
be featured absolutely cannot be
featured the editorial team for Google
Play will do nothing with your app in
terms of promotion unless you have a
feature graphic so make sure that you
add one and this is just one example of
what a few geographic could look like
the tasker it's it could be as simple as
just having your name and the icon there
maybe like a tagline or something but
make sure that it's also legible and
clearly you know delivers the message at
small sizes because you know this
feature graphic can appear in very very
small sizes on phones and in other
devices so yeah just say just to expand
on that just a little bit ya like like
Roman says this one same you know large
asset it's like 1024 pixels of wide when
you supply it and so people get tempted
to cram all kinds of information in
there but really really and resist that
because it can be shown very very small
if you think about a small handset kind
of like three inches like diagonally
handset it's going to be shrunken down
greatly so my advice to people is always
to get your future graphic and resize it
down to about a hundred pixels wide and
check that everything's kind of legible
and still looks good at that kind of
size and the other tip is that if you
are looking up to get featured the the
graphic can be shown in the Play Store
like on the front page without much
context so i always think find it's
helpful to have a happier future graphic
convey some of the meaning of what the
application actually does because
they're going to see it on its own
without the benefit of the title and the
description text in the screenshots so
really have it kind of stand alone yeah
and it could appear without the icon and
appear without the title so absolutely
stand like that it can appear Stan law
is a very very important point for a run
for future growth and resisting
screenshots in there because they don't
sighs very well and also include a
device frame it just has the ability to
update it very quickly so you have try
resist that absolutely
alright shall we move on to touch
feedback yep alright Adam you wanna
drive yeah sure so we wanted to discuss
a little bit about touch feedback we
actually look at a lot of different
applications in our role and
surprisingly one of the things we see
broken and a lot of them is touch
feedback which is strange because it
really does give the user a sense of
responsiveness and indicate that
something's happening within within the
application and the amount of effort
required to actually add good touch
feedback in the application is actually
not that much so it's definitely
something with sort of lower amounts of
effort that has great payoff and of
course the canonical source for
information on touch feedback is the
design side so if you just go on to
style there's a section called touch
feedback Kutless the next page there's a
bunch of states here and some more
information on sort of recommendations
of how you should actually style the
different states for touch feedback but
we have some tips I think on the next
screen yeah so you know the first thing
I remember is all interactive elements
should provide feedback lot some of them
every single one should provide some
sort of feedback if you like if it does
something it should do some it should
look like it does something when you
press it exactly at another point to
make is you should be consistent so we
often see people customizing touch
feedback for you know parts of the
application but then they don't go in
customers say the action bar touch
feedback so you have sort of the whole
of blue in the action bar but you have a
completely different color scheme for
the rest of your application one that
will run at one thing that can help with
that is the Android holo colors Android
holo colors website which basically
generates all that for developers as
well as the action bar style generator
which again does not offer to them yeah
combined that will really help you get
sort of ninety-nine percent through your
application being consistent there we'll
touch on this again in a second but you
should really ensure that the full
touchable target area has feedbacks
they're not just a portion of it you
know if its touchable elsewhere it
should really have feedback cross the
entire item as you mentioned customize
add feedback for custom components and
whatnot and also don't forget about the
multi select mode and contextual action
bar
you know those are really important
modes and you met you should really make
sure that there's a touch indicators
when you're in the multi-select look so
we've got some examples and we can
discuss some of these points on the on
the next slide here see well it'll load
and there it is yeah so this is just
some of the system apps to start we've
got a google plus on the left youtube in
the middle and the system gallery on the
right so one area i see a lot of people
leaving out touch feedback is when
they're sort of fully customizing a
listview soon got this long scrolling
list of items and they've really you
know customized it so in the case of
google plus they've got this sort of
nice cards youtube it's it's almost like
a card like interface but it's a it's a
rich items showing the youtube thumbnail
and very frequently will see people
forget to add the different states to
these kinds of list views so there's two
sort of different I guess different
types here that these apps have taken in
the in the Google+ app for example
they've covered the entire item in a
sort of blue highlight Oh a blue collar
are quite like that yeah like and
overlaying in in development terms is
basically the draw selector on top
attribute on this fusing 30 correct and
in the YouTube app they've gone the sort
of and showing the overlay so it's not
overly they're going to show underneath
the main thumbnail there so it's another
approach you can take it's really up to
you which one to choose personally I
like the the Google+ method a little bit
more but you know when you've got rich
graphics in your list you it's it's
really comes down to how you want to
display it here and then the third
screenshot shows the gallery and it's
got the contextual action bar activated
and you can see you know again it's got
the touch feedback there so that when
you select each of these it shows a nice
sort of blue hollow overlay actually you
get a lot of this for free using on
android 4.0 on ICS and above you get
this for free with I think the
selectable item background attribute so
if you use that throughout you don't
even have to like custom create all
these assets these blue assets it just
comes you know with the system with the
frame
so it's really really useful to just use
that to drop it in you know android
colon background equals this rental coma
foreground equals the select old
selectable item background thing and you
get a lot of you for free correct also
get the support library right is it oh
that's awesome that's great yeah yeah I
guess it's worth knowing as well like a
standard list for you if you use the
standard list items it will have touch
feedback for you but it's only when you
really customize these things that it
may not because you're building the
layouts from scratch yes I think yeah
the key thing is if you're customizing
your like providing your own like button
drawables and stuff like that make sure
you include all the custom states as
well right yeah it's a selector drawable
or stateless trouble so you should have
XML along with your PNG's that indicate
which PNG file which nine patch or
whatever should be used with each state
and while you are early in there
creating your kind of press States moves
also include the focus stakes as well
because devices with trackballs and
Google TVs and so on all really really
benefit from those days and while you're
at it do the right thing yes correct and
as I mentioned on the design side it has
some examples of how you should you know
how I should color and style those
particular different states or just use
under Holocaust yep so here's an example
of a third party app the Ted application
which we like to use as an example here
on the show there's three different
screens here now it's kind of hard to
see in the first screen but there's a
great highlight actually on the top left
top left part of the action bar as well
as all the times I kind of double tapped
here just so we could fit into one
screenshot obviously contorted your hand
yeah it's kind of hard to take a
screenshot at the same time but they've
got a arm sort of like gray highlight
here when when when the user touches
down and then if you look at these other
screenshots next to it you'll see four
other items including the action items
in the action bar we should move an
interview yeah sure let's
they've got a red highlight so they've
got two different highlights and they
kind of use them in four different items
across the application so places I guess
where the early using the you know the
sub trademark Ted red color they'll use
the gray highlight and other places
they'll use the red highlight so for
example in this button here which says
listen to this talk they've got the red
highlight again and this comes back to
that point we're talking about where you
should really highlight the entire
touchable area so you'll see here that
the whole red highlight is covering the
entire line because you can touch
anywhere across that entire line yeah so
like the first time you touch it you'll
probably touch around the icon or the
text but then when you see that you know
the rest of that row responds in red
you'll immediately your brain will will
internalize the fact that you know this
whole thing is a single object that you
can interact with so it really helps
make that Association yep and I think we
should move on yeah and then finally to
other two other types of touch feedback
worth mentioning there's boundaries and
communication so if you look here at the
left screen shot it's kind of hard to
see if you get the slides after the show
you about to see a bit easier but the
sort of this is showing the edge
resistance when you swipe down and
there's nothing more above the current
list so you've got the sort of blue glow
showing here at the top left in Google
Play I think of it's like a forcefield
you just run up and again it's it's
dissipating energy as its kinetic energy
is turning into light basically and this
is a for developers out there this is
the edge effect and edge effect compat
classes that let you do this on custom
views and of course using standard views
you'll get you get all this for free it
is worth like remembering how it looks
and how it behaves because you know you
don't want to have say blue colors at
the top there they might be clashing
with it it's quite interesting if you
use it when you can see they've
implemented their own kind of horizontal
paging you rather than using so another
view pager component and it doesn't give
you that that feedback when you've
reached the edge it just kind of feels
off right
yeah definitely for sure and then in the
second screen shot um it's the gallery
application and when you swipe to the
edge here it kind of has a 3d effect
where all the different thumbnails kind
of tilt to the side again showing
resistance so this is more more of a
custom implementation I guess so you
know you can definitely influence
something custom it's really up to you
personally I like the blue glow as we've
been talking about but depending on the
feel of your application the gallery is
very very much of a 3d sort of feel of
an application so that's why it's sort
of appropriate here and launcher has
something kind of similar as well but
the whole thing tilts and then finally I
just wanted to quickly mention this and
this is fairly advanced I can't imagine
that many app developers doing this but
this is concept of communication so for
touch gestures so in this example gmail
you've got the sort of swype to just
swipe to delete or swipe to archive as
you swipe you'll notice the actual items
that's to fade out slowly as you move
across more and if you slide back again
without actually completing the swipe it
will fade back in again so this is just
sort of hinting to the user that this
item is going to go away as you swipe it
off the screen so again it's you know
this is pretty custom and and and and
probably more advanced but definitely
suddenly think about if you have these
advanced gestures all right we better
keep moving about five minutes left
alright so let's fly through and
redesign you have fun you feel like six
or seven items but let's start with the
redesigns of the outlook.com map by
Taylor Ling and Samuel T from a hollow
they're really awesome work Sam even
basically did like a multi pain you I he
did a whole bunch of different screens
and taylor also kind of had his own take
on this app and he let us that actually
there are some similarities there's some
some very obvious ways to you know to
map in an older app to kind of the new
or holo styling this is just one example
of minor variations of that anything
they're both really good job sir let's
fly through to actually you hani in
response to their redesigns he also did
a post on the outlook.com app and
basically he gave some anecdotal
feedback or actually some some real
feedback i guess with some real data on
how you know when you release an app
that use using older kind of gingerbread
even you know Eclair donut styling for
newer devices meaning now if you release
that's about now users are going to
respond you know very negatively towards
that so be careful while doing that if
you're thinking about doing it just
don't do that is that the easy way and
then one of our one of our one of the
folks that submitted an entry for the
for the stencil give away a few weeks
ago gang gal he did a you I'm or a
couple of you I'm mock-ups for the
dribble a poor for what dribble could
look like on Android you know it is
pretty cool Nick you want to add
anything about but I'm just that I want
this yeah I saw your comment really want
! right yeah I feel the same way says it
all right okay next that we have we just
released yesterday the new version of
the Maps API for Android this is v2 of
the API it requires google play services
and that's all you need really there's
no separate bundle or anything it's
really just part of Google Play services
and this is basically if you want to get
you know vector tiles and 3d building
facades and all this cool new you know
3d maps stuff in your app you should
definitely switch over to this from the
original map view and this also works
for works with fragments and support
library fragments as well so you get a
lot of the benefits basically
everybody's been asking for this and
finally we're able to the big water yeah
I'm but if it for designers I guess the
key takeaways you now have maps kind of
threw out the application if you're a
developers have complained and set out
that's really hard to do that's no
longer the case as well as having some
pretty advanced features as well right
like so having a custom overlays and
different shapes and boundary boxes or
and so forth its really really allows
for any really cool interactions with
having maps yeah I'm really excited
about the different angles and panning
and tilting that you can do I think
that's going to work really nicely with
some of the apps that are out there and
remember you can cost you can design
custom marker icon so you know the
marker icons don't have to look like the
teardrop shape or a little circle shape
it could really you know represent it
could be it could use your branding if
you want you know it could be a custom
shape or whatnot so lots of options are
and there's this new website Android
views net which basically has a list a
collection of different custom views and
in different UI widgets and things and
this is kind of similar to the ultimate
Android library which is more broadly
scoped it covers you know libraries that
are for image caching and all sorts of
stuff but this is very specific to UI
widgets and it's a very nice
presentation of the different UI
elements you can using around it's very
pretty but I'm not sure about that icon
look at Steve me Android yeah it's like
a yeah it's exactly what I cast evening
enjoy he's very angry it's very angry
okay um next and Nikki want to talk
about Marie's post yeah so basically a
Marie is a regular doer and active
designer of community is trying to get
community of Android designers to kind
of color s and speak to each other more
I mean I certainly resonate with this
kind of em this kind of idea i think
when we're doing the design competition
there was a ton of activity going on on
google+ especially with people posting
on the hash android design and hashtag
and that was really cool i really like
to see that continues emery he's trying
to get everyone together if you follow
this QR code and and you comment on her
friend she's trying to put together a
circle of developer designers working
with android so comment on the post and
we'll try and share that around so
everyone can connect to each other and
start talking about android design all
right so we're at eleven o'clock let's
fly through the last couple of things i
recently did a blog post on designing
for tablets so if you're designing for
tablets which means hopefully everybody
that's watching check out this blog post
they will link you to things that you
may not have seen before def
kind of a good resource for designing
for tablets and even developing for
tablet and lastly we recently put out a
developer survey so if you're an Android
developer and you haven't filled out the
survey and you are thinking you know I
really wish that you know the Google
team or the Google Android team could do
this this or this fill out the survey
and let us know thank you I think that's
it for for stuff for this week as always
I am Roman Eric Adam gosh right thanks
Nick butcher thanks are you guys you
light up yeah see you next time peace
out